bonjour philippe qu'une merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin dans
la matinale darty france vous vous
trouvez devant fleury mérogis si je ne
me trompe vous avez décidé donc de de
manifester ce matin pour quelle raison
précisément
eh ben pour manifester contre cette
fameuse grille de fusion surveillants
surveillants brigadier qui ne nous
satisfait pas du tout qui qui ne
correspond pas du tout aux attentes que
les surveillants attendre et
pour comme vous disiez dans votre sujet
tout au début le ministre a été sommé
par le conseiller de l'elysée de nous
recevoir il a reçu une entente syndicale
et il a claqué la porte
fermons toutes problématiques de
négociation avec lui concernant cette
veille de fusion et claquer la porte
eric dupond moretti abbey s'est fâché il
s'est énervé en disant que de toute
façon il reviendrait pas sur ce qu'il a
fait que c'était bien on avait 30
millions d'euros et est terminée quoi
basta c'est pas la peine de discuter je
reviendrai pas sur ce que ce qui était
fait quoi c'est comme ça et puis c'est
tout alors que cette entente quand même
qu'il est représenté par le cs indique à
sps l'ufap et cgt représentent deux
tiers des personnels peu près 27 mille
surveillants donc on peut pas faire fi
de tous de tous ses personnels qu'est ce
qui va se passer précisément expliqué de
cette fusion des grades pourquoi vous
êtes contre
on n'est pas contre la fusion des gardes
au contraire c'était une de nos
revendications mais ce que ce qu'on
n'accepte pas c'est on a un indice
sommitale maximum de 500 2 nous on
voulait vous en voulez plus avec
l'entente syndicale en fin de carrière
des échelons qui sait qu'ils vont qui
sont trop longs 24 ans et demi de
carrière nous demander de 19 ans pour
que ce soit attractif c'est un métier
qui est déjà difficile on n'arrive pas à
recruter vous avez des échelons en fin
de carrière qui sont entre 2 ans et demi
voire trois ans sur les deux derniers
indices donc c'est juste pas possible il
ya eu aussi le relèvement de
de la grille indiciaire qui a été fait
pour tous les personnels de catégorie c
qui était oreos et a340 ce qui se passe
c'est que tous les nouveaux agents bas
c'est bénéfique pour eux mais les agents
qui sont ils sont situés en
intermédiaire de se pendre carrière bat
voix et 6 stagnent à stagner c'est pas
possible
c'est pas possible un surveillant qui
rentre dans la pénitentiaire gagne plus
qu'un quelqu'un qui est là depuis 4 ou 5
ans c'est ça ou on n'est pas content
il ya tous et tout ça et puis on
voudrait aussi par le biais de cette
fusion bien que si nous on obtient cette
fusion de surveillants à surveiller un
brigadier bas que en découlent aussi les
premiers surveillants et les majors
parce que à l'heure actuelle on était
obligés quand on voulait passer
surveillants brigadier de prendre des
passes et des unités de valeur c'est des
examens quoi vous aviez trois unités de
valeur à passer là dans cette grille de
fusion on passera directement brigadier
tout au long de sa carrière voilà donc
des réajustements dans cette réforme
vous vous pensez être reçu de nouveau
par par le ministre qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est ce que vous réclamez aujourd'hui
ben nous on avait bon on savait que le
ministre s'était c'était fini on avait
demandé simplement on avait envoyé des
lettres
l'entente syndicale avait envoyé des
lettres au cabinet du premier ministre
on avait envoyé un cabinet de l'élysée
aussi il a été sommé monsieur dupont
moretti de nous recevoir
forcer un peu la main par l'elysée est
arrivé là bas ça sert strictement à rien
quoi je veux dire là on est on est là il
veut pas ils veulent le passer en force
c'est donc on espère quand même que
oui excusez moi
vous espérez quand même ouais bah on
espère que la dgafp et
bercy vont quand même voir quand même
que c'est voilà que c'est pas c'est pas
un nombre à quoi c'est pas possible
qu'on laisse comme ça on recrutera
jamais voilà on veut aussi que ce soit
un tremplin pour la catégorie b aussi on
l'a milite depuis depuis de nombreuses
années donc maintenant ce qu'on voit là
là on a des personnels en colère voire
même résigné voyez moi je reviens que
sur ce gouvernement qui depuis quatre
ans depuis 2010 8,1 on revient un peu en
arrière on avait une grogne historique
de suite aux attentats terroristes
il avait mis une simplement trouver le
pas d'autre moyen que de nous museler
par des des sanctions quand on était
tous devant les portes d'une centaine
d'établissements qui s'étaient révoltés
par rapport à tout ça on a muselé les
âges on les a sanctionnés maintenant
vous voyez on a du mal à avoir
parce que c'est tellement facile de
sanctionner les agents qui sont en
colère et on peut pas peut pas avoir
servi le corps de direction on peut pas
avoir servi le corps de commandement
puisqu'avec des réformes justes avant
avant les nôtres et est la base bien lui
donner c'est inadmissible inadmissible
là votre mouvement c'est de bloquer les
centres carcéraux pendant combien de
temps oui bayard il ya eu aujourd'hui
c'est une journée d'action parce que il
y avait un comité technique ministériel
qui a été boycotté en début de semaine
l'administration pour normalement quand
vous voyez côté on doit avoir une
semaine pour leur faire ils l'ont remis
deux jours à 3 4 jours 3 jours après
donc c'est tout simplement pour nous
pour ça et le plus vite possible pour
faire passer cette réforme qui est
comportement inacceptable c'est g
c'est une honte coincé tu ne peux pas
voilà bon ça a été validé par un
syndicat majoritaire c'est ça le
problème à l'heure actuelle je suis pas
là pour leur faire de la publicité mais
je trouve que on devrait un peu regardé
tous les syndicats à marcher ensemble on
n'en serait pas là où on n'en serait pas
là et ça fait plusieurs années que ça
dure ça malheureusement le constat on
l'a où on l'a aujourd'hui on a
aujourd'hui une réforme qui doit être
passée en force
merci beaucoup affirment qu'une de nous
avoir répondu ce matin en direct dans la
matinale de rtl france bah je vous
remercie et bonne fin de journée
[Musique]